I was gonna say too like you were very
like engaged with what was going on in
New York too for being a West Coast guy
yeah I grew up in New York I moved here
when I was 12 and then um I would always
go back I would always stay out there I
had an apartment out there for like 15
years yeah I would always be in here you
guys did the second Cypress Hill album
yeah because you know back then we
started you blow up and then it's just
too much [__] going on
friends [__] everybody hanging out I was
like let's go over here which is US
locked in a room by ourselves yeah I'm
sure you guys in L.A after that first
album the studio sessions yeah couldn't
help but be distracted and everybody was
you couldn't and um everybody was busy
you know there's all these new people
around and this and that and millions of
dollars you know we're 21 years old so
it was like let's go to New York and
it's just us getting up going to the
studio
back to the crib back to the studio
that's all we did that shit's Fire Man
and we knocked that [__] out in a month
the record we knocked that record out of
the month the label was like we need
that [__] now so we went in and
knocked it out right quick I suppose the
first record took like three four years
it was a whole life you know up to that
point in the second one
I think we only did I think some of the
songs even came out before I think we
only did eight songs new ones because we
had um
um hand on the Glock it already came out
uh hdk came out a white man can't jump
soundtrack yep you know I mean there was
a couple interludes on there so
you know some of that [__] came out
already but that [__] was [__] and
soundscam was brand new when that record
came out
oh yeah yeah yeah I forgot sound scan
wasn't around like just came out like in
between our first and second album
no it's crazy too because I just think
like in terms of like you know for
whatever reason I feel like somehow
Cypress Hill gets like overlooked when
we talk about like goat conversations
like greatest groups of all time I mean
I feel like if you grew up in in LA or
you grew up on the west coast you
understand but I feel like for whatever
reason you guys are not underrated but
somehow underrated does that make sense
like you guys are still doing festivals
it's I mean platinum records but I still
feel like for whatever reason like like
we got to bring up that name in the mix
more when we talk about the greatest
groups of all time right right
yeah man I don't know [__] I can give a
[__] you know I mean what we set out to
do we're doing it you know what I mean
so that's all I give a [__] about so how
did you end up uh getting a House of
Payne back in the day before because I I
you I know I know you guys had a little
falling out for a sec but it was an
accident man like I was dating this girl
that actually was cousins of everlast's
DJ and I would go over there and he'd be
at the crib and I'd be like all right
and the Cyprus demo the Cyprus we were
signed already but the album I had the
album on a red cassette and I gave it to
her but the album didn't come out for
six months
so the next time I went over there a
couple times Everlast was there he was
listening to the tape he's like yo we
got to get in the studio I was like nah
I'm good man
and after three or four times I was like
I was talking to be real and B Rose like
man just [__] would [__] with him I was
like all right so I went in and did put
your head out in the crib and I was like
okay this is cool then the homies was
bumping it and then I was like I got the
song called Jump Around
so I had already recorded it with
sunduby I recorded it with Daddy Freddie
from ragamuffin hip hop and I had a song
I had the hook
he came in and wrote the [__] and I was
like now rewrite it with that Cadence
right there and he wrote the [__] and
then we had the joint and to one of the
greatest party songs of all time shop
the deal man I know Funkmaster Flex
wanted to sign a set priority records
for like I think it was like 55 60 G's
he had special ed over there at the time
I didn't even know Funk Flex worked the
priority yeah crazy and then um it was
weird because Monica Lynn show for a
Tommy Boy wanted to sign us and um so I
went and had a meeting with her and she
was like she was Irish so she's like
this reminds me of my family this is
like my brothers would go to church
then they go to uh to the bar and get
drunk and fight
she got it right off the bat you know I
mean so she signed us she gave us like
300 back then
and then uh I hooked my people art
management the guys who did our our
pictures I hooked up with those guys and
and David Perez who did our video I'll
come up with them so it was pretty much
the formula so you kind of just take
here's our formula run with it run with
it and it worked with it like a
[__] like a [__] yo I
always wondered so there was like this
era um I'm really close with Dilated
Peoples and raqqa and ivory science and
Baboo and obviously shots are they the
best hell yeah I love those guys
um
they really opened my world or my taste
in another a whole nother way
um to like digging into like different
[__] that I was into at the time but I
remember as a kid there was the random
because you were close like you were
cool with Paul obviously right you're
cool with M but then there's like this
weird beef between like Dilated Peoples
Everlasting Eminem did you ever try to
like bring those guys together nah it
was weird man I think I think Everlast
from what I remember correctly you know
don't quote me here but I think ever
last seen M on the elevator and M just
didn't say nothing to him but M's like
he didn't look the same right and didn't
realize that he didn't realize who he
was right right and and was a [__]
Everlast fan you know from what I hear
so ever that's just you know I don't
know what happened then he wrote some
[__] about him yeah and then I remember
there was like the dilated [__] and then
evidence had a song called uh Searching
for Bobby Fischer so I was just
wondering because you were kind of like
it felt like I live in Switzerland you
might have you know I don't know if
you're trying to put a call in none no I
just figured all that oh y'all [__] up
yeah you know [__] with them good
luck with that [__] man good luck I mean
like even why but um I don't even think
I heard the dilated song ever yeah there
was an Evidence song called Searching
for Bobby Fischer that was like I heard
that one no but I had um a Napster hit
yeah so yeah I brought Paul I remember
when I met Paul I flew him out to L.A to
meet with me and I had a barbecue um to
manage Cyprus and he came out here and
that's how I met Paul because Theo Theo
was my lawyer and I was like yo I need a
new manager bro
what year was this before um before um
rock superstar album so it was like 2099
yeah 99 and I was he's like yo I got
this this lawyer he's got an ear like me
and he's managing this artist Eminem and
didn't blow up here yeah
flew his ass out had a barbecue and
locked in with Paul
what what was was it labeled like why
did you guys do a rap Superstar and a
rock superstar difference because um
check this out so we was up at Columbia
and you know now we're going into the
fifth album
so we'd go to the urban Department that
was after the album after Dr
greenthumber before after after that's
right okay it was like yeah that was
four that was the fifth album yeah so we
would go up to the label and was like
all right let's go this marketing plan I
go to the urban Department it was like
no no you guys are you guys are
alternative I know we ain't so we go up
to the other we go up to the next floor
and they was like oh no you guys are the
urban Department
and they didn't work together and
everybody's passing the buck nobody
wanted to do their [__] job and I was
like you my [__] pieces of [__] check
this out I'm gonna give you all a rock
song and a rap song So now what's your
[__] excuse you got one you got one
so I did we had a song called can't get
the best of me and rap Superstar
and then I walked into the meeting with
Donnie Aina and he was like no this is
the single we're not doing rock song
with this is the single I'm putting all
the money behind this one I was like oh
[__] this ain't gonna work so I went in
the studio a couple days later and did
the remix for Box Superstar wow okay